so this review is going to be a little
bit different than normal reviews most
of the time i review games that i'm kind
of anticipating i pretty much choose
what i want to review on the iron lord's
podcast channel uh but when i went to
pax i end up playing this game that i'm
about to review and i remember when i
first saw it on the list of games that
we had scheduled for interview it didn't
really appeal to me i felt like maybe
this is something that someone else
should be playing because the type of
gameplay didn't really vibe with me but
you know i went ahead and went through
with the interview and i've actually
really happy i did so we got the review
code
and here i am to talk about it uh and
this is pretty much the story of how a
game that i had zero interest in turned
out to be a really fun time and what is
that game you might ask it's euden
chronicle rising published by 505 games
and developed by rabbit and bear studio
but you guys know how it is before you
get to this review man hit that like
button if you guys enjoyed this review
you can always subscribe to the channel
for weekly podcast weekly content and
don't forget to go and follow us on
twitter at the iron lords podcast and
without any further ado here's my review
on a union chronicle rising for steam
[Music]
what's going on you guys lord act here
coming at you for another review
reviewing something for the iron lords
podcast we usually go to these events we
went to pax and i played this there and
it kind of caught my interest now at
first it didn't really resonate with me
because the gameplay normally i stay
away from type of games like this but
the sequel is going to be
a turn based game and for those of you
that follow the channel you know that
lord addict loves his turn-based games
and i felt like if i didn't at least
give this game a try when it came to
playing the turn based game it would
confuse me on what's going on because
this is actually a prequel to that game
now we can debate all along here if it's
a smart move for them to go with this
type of gameplay you know the the
side-scrolling metrovania type of
gameplay when the actual sequel is going
to be completely different and i feel
like that argument is valid you could
actually argue that maybe they should
have had a better chance of going into
what type of gameplay they have for here
but first thing we want to talk about is
the performance and the graphics this
game has a pretty unique art style now
i'm not going to say it's like gorgeous
or anything like that i do feel like in
terms of these type of games they should
have more stuff going on in the
background kind of like you know ori in
the blind forest it's a very beautiful
game but you want to get the beautiful
with the immersion as well and when you
do these like art draw style type of
games i feel like you can do more with
the background if it's going to be
stationary now is the entire game
stationary no is any of it really
stationary probably not but i do feel
like there is a lot more that could be
going down in the background and you
know the performance was actually pretty
good now i don't know what this game
runs like on the switch i'm pretty sure
it's probably on the xbox series s and x
i'm confident those run pretty good on
that and the playstation now if it is on
the switch and i'm pretty confident on
the switch i don't know how it's gonna
run on there uh that's the only one that
i want you guys to be a little bit very
on maybe look up a youtube video or two
on what the performance like this game
is on the switch it doesn't seem like a
very demanding game so i don't think
that's gonna be a huge issue now let's
move on to the story of this game i
actually want to be very vocal the story
comes out with some type of earthquake
happening in a town i don't really
really want to give out the town name
because i feel like that is spoiling to
a point maybe not like to a huge point
but it is spoiling but it goes in this
town you have these villagers that are
pretty much got screwed over because of
this earthquake and i don't mean a
little bit guys everything was bulldozed
to the ground pretty much this whole
village is screwed and you have all of
these adventurers coming around from
around the world trying to explore these
caverns so they can find treasure take
it back to wherever they came from it's
pretty much about
furthering themselves now the town
itself like i said it is destroyed the
earthquake pretty much demolished
everything so what what do you do in
that situation the mayor of that town
actually has set this type of stamp
system up and how this stamp system
works is the adventures that go there if
you fill up a stamp system she gives you
a license to where you can actually go
explore stuff now the thing i will say
that doesn't really make sense in terms
of the stamp system when it comes to the
story is if you have all these
adventures coming from around the land
and the mayor has set these precautions
these requirements to get a license to
do this stuff i feel like the town would
be a lot more functional than it really
is you get there and they say they have
all these travelers that are down by the
lake or whatever there was a certain
section of the game that they said
they're at and you didn't really even
come across a whole lot of them i had
all these people around here and you
never really come across too many
travelers felt like that was actually a
misstep by itself now obviously you come
across some of the people in your team
that are part of those travelers and you
come across you know pretty much someone
that the mayor hired that is part of
those travelers but you don't come
across a vast majority of those people
and i feel like that is something they
should have done but you know if you
have all these people around here trying
to
explore these caverns trying to get all
these treasures i feel like they all if
they're in the stamp system they would
be doing the same thing that you're
doing to fix this town and it didn't
feel like that it kind of felt like the
stamp system was only set for you now
she did say in the game that if you have
a sizeable amount of money you don't
have to use the stamp system that she
has but to me i felt like this was put
into the game strictly to encourage you
to help the villagers and not
necessarily put in the game that made
sense to the lower part but that's just
a nitpick for the most part one of the
things i didn't like about this game
like
whatsoever and i feel like a lot of
these indie games i don't know the
logistics behind two voice acting and
i'm not saying this game needed voice
acting i'm saying it would have been a
very good feature that they should have
tried to put in this game i don't know
what the stretches were to their
kickstarter but i do know that when i'm
seeing all this dialogue and keep in
mind there's a lot of dialogue in this
game there is an absurd amount of
dialogue in this game i never felt like
it was like overborn but i did feel like
i was reading more than i was playing
games sometimes but when there's no
voice to it you don't hear that dialogue
and start merging yourself into the
character's voice you know the emotion
that's in the voice then maybe
i feel like that hurts the game more
than it helps it now obviously like i
said i don't know the legislant i don't
know how much it costs to realistically
do some type of
voice overs in these games and kind of
give you a personality some of these
people now i have seen at other studios
where they'll have the actual people
there regardless if it's devs you know
community manager where they'll voice
some of them and that's a pretty good
cheaper alternative way of doing this
now obviously if you get an actual voice
actor you're going to get probably a
better quality voice depending on who it
is but it's just like i do feel like
we're coming to the point where even
indie games should really try to have
voice overs on these characters to bring
them alive i was just playing final
fantasy 7 and my mind didn't even think
about it because it's an old game i
expect that from those older type games
but it's kind of ridiculous that i play
a 2022 game and i'm still getting the
same type of reading scroll text like
that i was getting back in the 90s and
i'm not it's like i said i know
that it's budgeting it's just i feel
like this going forward if you really
want to try to make your game succeed as
much as possible you're going to have to
try to make that voiceover and do
whatever you can to do it now earlier i
was talking about the stamp system and
how bad it was implemented in terms of
story-wise but let's talk about the good
things that that system has put into
this game it's put a unique kind of
perspective on this type of city builder
that you have going on here where all of
these villagers have these broken down
shops and stuff and they ask you for
certain materials that you have to go
into these dungeons for to rebuild these
buildings so you can later on buy
potions get upgrades upgrade your swords
upgrade
the abilities that you have by upgrading
some of the equipment that you have and
i think that's unique i don't i think a
lot more people need to take advantage
of this i'm a very
i need to do this type of person now
side quest is a little bit different but
usually when you reward me with
you know extravagant stuff i will do
just about any type of fetch quest and i
actually felt very rewarded everything i
did in this game for these villagers it
made me actually care about what these
villagers were going through because i
needed to buy stuff from them i enjoyed
that now it's like i said i think the
stamp system could have been done a
little bit better but as far as the
reward sensation that they give you for
helping this village
get back on its feet i gotta give my hat
to them because that kind of sensation
is hard to give gamers to where you
actually feel accomplished and you feel
like you got something for the work that
you put into and for the most part i
never felt like i wasn't getting my
money's worth when i was helping these
people do something i knew that the
moment that shop went up it was going to
lead me to more resources lead me to
more weapons you can get pawn shops in
here you can open uh you know potion
shops you can open farms there was
plenty to do that would keep you busy
and you felt like you was getting
rewarded and i got it's like i said that
is hard to do in the studio over there
at rabbit and bear studio they're doing
really good job in terms of giving you
that incentive to going out and helping
this village now let's talk about the
gameplay you guys know
that that's that's the only part i
really care about you know a story can
be bad and if the game plays fantastic i
usually always finish the game because
the game plays fun but vice versa if the
story is really good but the gameplay is
bad most of the time i drop it and when
i played this at pax this was the
highlight it felt good now i will say
that there is an issue in this game on
pacing in terms of how fast your
character goes most the time i felt like
he was just carrying over to cj and the
moment she died you wanted to go back or
throw a potion on her or go back to the
town and heal up because if he was
forced to use the other two characters
in this game that was not cj
it was not a very good experience while
traveling now clearly the other
characters had their own unique purposes
that you would use them throughout the
map you know it's like kind of kind of
like a metrovania thing going on now
sure i feel like the metro va could have
been done a little bit better usually it
was pretty much done by if you got a
certain move from a character or you got
a certain element from you know these
little rocks that you'll be able to
destroy them i don't really necessarily
think it's very light metro fanny it's
not huge metropane yet but when it comes
to the traveling the biggest issue i see
in this game is there's no
clear run button there's no accelerate
button it's usually all just one speed
now i will say cj has a dash button now
the dash button isn't the point itself
you can upgrade this dash button further
on the game when you fix certain parts
of the town to where you can dash in air
if the dash lasts longer but i think the
biggest issue is the fact that there's
no
run button in general with every
character
once again outdated practices to me
we're in 2022 i feel like every game
should have another speed automatically
that you could press a button and run
press a button and jog walk fast
something now sure with cj relatively
fast without some type of run button yes
but oh my gosh sometimes i'm running
through these maps and i feel so
slow and i i have an issue with that now
look i don't know how easy it is to
patch a run button in the game but if
you guys hear this over there please do
that i'm not saying it's something
that's essential but to me when i play
these type of games especially these
action-adventure side-scrolling games i
want to be able to travel the map at a
relatively fast speed you had myself at
the end of this game utilizing abilities
that wasn't meant for speed it was meant
to you know get behind it in me without
taking damage or you know skipping
through an attack i was using the dash
on the ground jumping up and dashing
again just to get through the map faster
we have seen this type of app behavior
throughout the history of games where
people in zelda roll all the time
because they physically feel like that
is getting them to their destination
faster and that is probably the
single-handed
biggest issue i have when it comes to
the game play in this game is the fact
that sometimes it feels extremely slow
and i think that that should be tweaked
before anything else just give me a run
button that's all you got to do just
give me a run button combat in this game
at the beginning feels a little bit dull
but once you get through the game you
start unlocking more abilities start
unlocking harder enemies that take
unique weapons that you have or someone
else that's on your team has to defeat
them you really see what they did and
they did it well i can honestly say that
regardless with the run button this the
combat on this game
is so
satisfying and one of the biggest reason
the combat is so satisfying is this
feature in this game called link systems
what is a link system you may ask addict
a link system is something like marvel
vs capcom where you tag another
character in and you hit them and you
use that character from them on out
until you tag them out to another
character there's three characters in
this you can tag
three characters at any times you want
now there is a certain amount of times
that you have to tag that you have to
let it actually cool down and the way to
upgrade how many you can do in a row is
to level up your card system or the
stamp system once you have that full
thing stamped and you get a new card it
will actually unlock another link on the
link system that you can do where you
can continuously tag other people and do
massive amounts of damage to your enemy
and some of these opponents some of
these creatures in this game are kind of
difficult if you don't use the link
system and i feel like the thing that
makes the league system
so great and so satisfying is just the
way you can utilize it for instance you
have a mage on here she throws fireballs
ice balls really anything you want that
you attach her element to
and what i would enjoy doing is throwing
a fireball the moment that fireball or
whatever element is attached to her hits
that other person what's going to happen
is you can press the button that
corresponds to the other people and they
will teleport where that fireball hit
them it doesn't matter she's halfway
across that map and you threw the
fireball and hit him the moment you
pressed that y button gorgo was going to
show up and hit them immediately and i
really enjoyed it was very satisfying
sometimes you can set up link attacks to
kill entire groups easy as long as you
knew the correct patterns to do this
game didn't really seem to have a whole
lot of options in terms of weapons i
felt like they you know maybe we could
have changed that maybe cj could have
went to a spear type of combat i get
that you know this is how they want them
to play and that's probably for the most
part why they did it i assume these
characters are going to be in their next
game and they want them to fight a
certain way because in the turn-based
game it's going to be important over
there so we're not going to really gripe
them too much on that what i like about
this is you could change the elements of
them like i was saying earlier you can
make it to where gorgon attacks he
shoots lightning out of his sword when
he attacks now it's not like a long
range lightning or thing like that it's
just pretty much your sword is embedded
with lightning cj same thing i had fire
in her sword her daggers so what i
really liked is they took that feature
and they combined it with metrovania
elements that they had in this game
you'll be going around the map and there
will be incidences where you come across
these big you know fire boulders or an
enlightening boater or an ice boulder i
don't think ice was part of maybe it was
i don't know i can't remember but it
will be elemental boulders that surround
the map where when you embed that
character with that element and they hit
that certain rock that rock's gonna get
destroyed and that's really the only
kind of metrovania element that's in
this but and i feel like that's fine you
know if you want to draw a line in the
sand of this is
as far as we're willing to go in the
metro venue totally up to you i didn't
see too much of an issue with it i
didn't grade this on a metro vendi like
scale so it doesn't really matter in
terms of scale on how much of they used
in this actual game now let's talk about
the bosses this game's got a quite a bit
of bosses and the good thing about i
will say about the ball system in here
is the majority of them do respawn so
you can fight them over and over again
and they do level up with you depending
on how far you are in the game i do know
that once i beat the game all of them
went to level 30 but at that time even i
felt like if they were five to ten
levels higher than me it was never
really a moment where i felt like i was
in danger for the most part they got
like two to three moves and they never
really change anything up and i think
that's the biggest issue developers
need to understand that is 2022 and with
the success of franchises like dark
souls
anything related to that type of combat
they've shown that when it comes to ball
spices the entire industry needs to step
their game up i want bosses to change
patterns i want bosses to change
appearances and sometimes i want bosses
to do all of that there shouldn't be a
situation where you're fighting a boss
and he never switches up it's like he's
willingly
asking to get over and over again and
he's not changing anything up and to me
that's not realistic if you get hit over
and over again and clearly what you're
doing is not working you're naturally
going to switch things up so that's why
i feel like look some of the bosses on
here should have changed their patterns
i do know there was a type of a fire
snake that you fought and there was a
backdrop that i really liked there was
lava moving around and the whole time
i'm fighting the only thing i could
think of is would it be cool if you got
this dude half his health he goes into
love and he comes up behind you and he
just keeps throwing fireballs behind you
and you don't even have to try to hit
him there you maybe that's just a damage
phase that he does to you that you got
to wait for it to be over with and you
just got to dodge him now i know that
what i'm asking a lot of you are going
to feel like i'm just trying to make the
game harder i think it's too easy that's
not the point i do think the game is a
pretty easy game but i don't think it
was designed to be hard and that's okay
you can make boss fights that are very
appealing and have very good boss
mechanics without the game being hard
some of the best dark soul fights aren't
hard it's just the boss is cool and i
think that's what we need to do more
often in the gaming industries have
better more immersive bosses and i
didn't feel like none of the bosses were
immersive now they were cool they were
fun to fight and maybe it was because i
was destroying them pretty fast and like
i said i have a very big history with
these type of games these dark souls
type of games now this isn't a dark soul
game this is more of like a a building
management collecting resource game and
that's okay because i don't think this
is designed to be like a huge scale
project this was designed to broaden the
horizon and get you ready for their next
game which is 100 heroes which is going
to be the turn-based game that comes out
in 2023.
look regardless what they've done to set
up that game i can't i got to be real
with you guys ryzen was a fun game
coming from a person that went to pax
that didn't really feel what i saw
before i played the game but when i
played the game i sensed potential there
i sense this game might actually be fun
to play you guys know i'm a huge fan of
gameplay i will play gameplay over
anything else and i knew when i picked
up the sticks when i was playing ryzen
that was going to be worth my time at
least and i got the review code and i
reviewed it now it's twenty dollars and
that's what i said i don't think this
game was ever designed to be a huge
product it's twenty dollars and i think
it represents what you get what you get
is a solid
action-adventure side-scrolling game
kind of a little of a city builder
management resources type of game and a
boss
speculation that you can fight over and
over again and i think that's okay
this is definitely worth it keep in mind
it's in game pass day and date you can
go download it right now on game pass
unless it's been took in the future i
don't know when you guys are watching
this and i think that this game is
definitely worth your 20 bucks you can
get a good 15 to 20 hours in this and if
you're not as good at the boss fights
that i was because of previous
experience in these type of games when
it comes to boss fights you might get
even more than that and never one time i
felt like the bosses were boring they
just i felt like they could have evolved
and that's all this game is definitely
worth your money i feel like you know go
out there and get it if you like the
gameplay you see in the background
twenty dollars what what is that some
some money at mcdonald's you could you
can definitely support a developer that
deserves it i do feel like the twenty
dollars is a representation of the game
you get and it's a fun game it's a game
that you can put up 10 to 15 or 20 hours
into and feel very satisfied and that's
my review on eden chronicle rising i'm a
huge of what i played and i feel like
the majority of you that are liking this
if you like games and you especially
like side scrollers and a little bit of
metrovania you're gonna like this game
it's on steam xbox playstation switch
and it's on game pass like i said it's
worth your money worth your time and
that's all that's my review on this i
hope you guys enjoyed it and it gets it
gets the stamp man it's the iron lord
stamp i do think it deserves it and
until next time this is lord addict and
i'm out of here peace